this is an interesting story that I
thought I'd bring up with you today
there's been a debate recently over the
claim that Elizabeth Warren predicted
the 2008 financial crisis before it
happened and most of the focus on the
story has been on the wrong thing most
of the focus has been on determining did
Elizabeth Warren predict the financial
crisis or did she not actually predict
the financial crisis but I don't
actually think that that's the right
argument at all to be having I'll tell
you the facts first and then I'll tell
you why I think the entire conversation
is being framed incorrectly 2020
Democratic candidate Elizabeth Warren
did a CNN Town Hall and one of the
things that she said was that she
predicted the 2008 financial crisis she
said quote and starting in the early
2000s the crisis was coming I was waving
my arms ringing the bell doing
everything I could I said families are
getting cheated all over this country it
started when the mortgage companies
targeted communities of color they
targeted seniors they targeted Latinos
they came in and sold the worst-possible
mortgages and stripped wealth out of
those communities and then took those
products across the nation I went
everywhere I could I talked about it to
anyone who would listen a crisis is
coming so is this true that she did this
basically it is okay before 2008
Elizabeth Warren was talking about the
impending housing and financial crisis
in her 2003 book she talked about it
subprime lending and housing crisis in
2004 on PBS she said that the growing
household debt the growing number of
risky mortgage lending practices are
causing a problem in 2005 she told the
New York Times that the amount of home
equity debt that homeowners were getting
into was a big red flag and PolitiFact
looked at this and determined yes
Elizabeth Warren did predict the
financial crisis but here's my reaction
so what Elizabeth Warren did predict the
financial crisis but why is that a big
deal tons of people predicted it tons
are predicting another crisis now and
none of it is even remotely notable it
requires special insight to predict but
what I mean by that is obviously our
economics
and circumstances are not sustainable of
course there's always a financial crisis
or a major downturn somewhere on the
horizon the question is is it a year
away or four years away or eight years
away I don't know how notable it is that
Elizabeth Warren predicted something
that anyone who understands the
boom-and-bust cycles of our economic
system has been predicting as a matter
of fact for decades or for as long as
they've been following the economy these
boom-bust cycles are implicit and
inherent to the economic system that we
have they're always on the horizon the
question is just when so one of the
reactions to this entire Elizabeth
Warren thing has been well we would care
about whether she did or didn't predict
it because we should want a president
who has the foresight to predict when
the next crisis will be well okay that
may be but anybody who understands how
the economy works should understand that
there's always a looming crisis on the
horizon there's always a looming
downturn on the horizon because it's
implicit to the system we have the
vulture capitalist cycles of boom and
bust that increase inequality an
increased despair don't happen less
frequently unless we actually deal with
the problems inherent to the system that
we have so Elizabeth Warren predicted it
tons of people predicted it and anybody
who understands our system understands
that such a crisis is always on the
horizon it's great that Elizabeth Warren
is actually talking about it but having
the foresight to predict it is actually
not notable although I'm glad that it is
getting more attention